L'image que vous voyez ici
est celle du suaire de Turin.
Il s'agit d'un grand drap sur lequel
on peut distinguer
l'image d'un homme barbu,
aux cheveux mi-longs
et présentant des blessures caractéristiques
au visage, aux poignets, aux pieds,
ainsi que de multiples taches
tout autour du cuir chevelu.
Ce linceul, conservé depuis le 16e siècle
dans la cathédrale de Turin
a longtemps été vénéré comme une relique.
Il s'agirait en effet du drap dans lequel
aurait été enveloppé le Christ
après la crucifixion.
Mais le 13 octobre 1988, une datation
au carbone 14 a rendu son verdict,
le suaire ne serait âgé que de 700 ans
et il aurait donc été confectionnés
au Moyen-Âge.
Bien qu'elle ait été demandée
par le Vatican
et parfaitement acceptée
par l'église catholique,
cette analyse a évidemment fait couler
beaucoup d'encre
et quelques irréductibles en contestent
encore la validité.
Alors comment ça marche, cette histoire
de carbone 14?
Est-ce qu'on peut s'en servir
pour dater n'importe quoi,
des objets ou des fossiles
aussi vieux qu'on veut?
Est-ce que ça permettrait de connaître l'âge
de Michel Drucker?
Eh bien non!
Il y a quand même des limites
à la technique,
pour les comprendre on va s'intéresser
aux principes physiques
qui se cachent derrière la datation au
carbone 14 et on illustrera ça
avec quelques-unes de ses utilisations
les plus célèbres en archéologie.
[Musique]
Alors commençons par quelques rappels.
Les atomes qui nous entourent sont fait
de protons et de neutrons
qui forment le noyau atomique
et autour duquel on trouve
des électrons.
Dans l'état de base, le nombre d'électrons
est égal au nombre de protons
et c'est lui qui détermine la nature
chimique de l'atome,
de quel élément il s'agit dans
le tableau périodique.
Par exemple, avec deux protons
c'est de l'hélium.
6 protons du carbone,
8 protons de l'oxygène, 2
6 protons du fer etc.
Mais le nombre de neutrons,
eh bien ça dépend!
Dans un noyau il y en a en gros à peu près
autant que de protons
mais il peut exister plusieurs variantes
d'un même élément,
on appelle cela les isotopes
de cet élément.
Prenons l'exemple de l'hélium,
son noyau contient toujours deux protons,
mais il peut avoir entre 1 et 8 neutrons,
alors pour distinguer ces différents isotopes,
on leur attribue un numéro
qui est la somme du nombre de protons
et de neutrons,
De l'hélium. avec un seul neutron,
c'est de l'hélium 3,
deux neutrons c'est de l'hélium 4,
trois neutrons c'est de l'hélium 5, etc.
À noter: la façon dont on l'écrit
traditionnellement:
on place ce nombre en haut,
avant le symbole de l'élément.
En théorie on peut imaginer
des tas d'isotopes
pour un même élément du tableau périodique,
Mais en pratique, seuls quelques-uns
existent et la plupart sont instables.
Dans le cas de l'hélium, seul l'hélium 3
et l'hélium 4 sont stables
et on les trouve, à l'état naturel,
dans des proportions très différentes.
L'immense majorité c'est de l'hélium 4,
et seul un atome d'hélium sur un million
est de l'hélium 3,
les autres isotopes de l'hélium
sont instables
c'est-à-dire qu'ils finissent toujours
par se transformer en autre chose.
Prenons le cas de l'hélium 6:
2 protons, 4 neutrons,
eh bien, au bout d'un moment un des neutrons
va se transformer en proton
en émettant un électron,
et donc le noyau va globalement devenir
un noyau de lithium 6.
Eh oui, il y a maintenant 3 protons
donc on change d'éléments dans
le tableau périodique.
Prenons un autre élément: l'oxygène
qui contient 8 protons,
son isotope stable le plus abondant
c'est l'oxygène 16
avec 8 neutrons mais son isotope
avec seulement 7 neutrons,
l'oxygène 15 lui est instable,
il se transforme en azote 15
c'est à dire que cette fois un proton
s'est transformé
en un neutron en émettant un positron
au passage.
Chaque fois qu'il y a
une transformation de ce type,
les particules et les rayonnements qui sont
émis peuvent causer des dommages
aux matériaux, aux cellules vivantes et
c'est ce qu'on appelle la radioactivité,
et on parle donc de désintégration
radioactive.
Le terme francophone de désintégration
est parfois un peu trompeur,
car il peut laisser penser que les noyaux
instables disparaissent
ou explosent en plein de morceaux, alors
qu'il s'agit juste de transformation.
Un point essentiel pour notre histoire
c'est que, bien qu'elles se produisent
dans les isotopes instables
ces transformations ne sont pas toujours
immédiates.
Prenons un tas d'atomes d'oxygène 15,
imaginons qu'on en ait 1000 au départ,
si on attend 10 secondes en moyenne,
5 % de ces noyaux vont se désintégrer,
il en restera donc environ 950, et ensuite,
toutes les dix secondes,
ce sont à chaque fois 5 % des noyaux
d'oxygène 15 restants
qui se désintègrent, comme il en reste
de moins en moins, au fur et à mesure,
il y a aussi de moins en moins
de désintégration,
la courbe du nombre d'atomes restants
va donc ressembler à ça:
C'est une décroissance exponentielle.
Pour caractériser le rythme
de cette décroissance
on regarde le temps qu'il faut pour que
la moitié du tas initial ait disparu,
c'est ce qu'on appelle la demi-vie
de l'isotope.
Dans le cas de l'oxygène 15, on peut voir
sur la courbe de décroissance
que cette demi-vie est d'environ 120 secondes
soit deux minutes.
Une chose importante à avoir en tête
concernant cette désintégration
c'est qu'il s'agit d'un phénomène aléatoire,
on pourrait s'imaginer que les noyaux
instables vieillissent
et quand ils ont passé un certain âge,
ils se désintègrent, mais non!
La désintégration radioactive est un truc
spontanée et complètement imprévisible,
à chaque instant qui passe chaque noyau
à une certaine probabilité
de se désintégrer, mais autrement
il ne change pas du tout.
Petite parenthèse pour les fans
de mécanique quantique
une manière de comprendre ce caractère
aléatoire
c'est de le voir comme un phénomène
d'effet tunnel.
Comme je l'ai dit, on quantifie le rythme
des désintégrations radioactives
à l'aide de la demi-vie,
le temps qu'il faut
pour que la moitié des noyaux
se soient désintégrés,
ça ne dépend pas de la quantité
qu'il y a au départ,
mais ça va dépendre de l'isotope.
Cette demi-vie est donc d'environ
deux minutes pour l'oxygène 15
mais ça peut être très très variable
pour l'hélium 5 la demi-vie
est d'une yocto-seconde,
alors une yocto-seconde, c'est un millionième
de milliardième de milliardième de seconde,
c'est pas beaucoup!
À l'opposé, pour le tellure 128, la demi-vie
c'est deux yotta-années
c'est-à-dire 2 millions de milliards
de milliards d'années,
donc si vous prenez un kilo de tellure 128
et que vous le regardez pendant un an,
il y a peut-être un de ses atomes
qui va se désintégrer.
Alors là je vous donne des cas extrêmes
mais des isotopes instables,
il en existe plein, de tous les éléments
du tableau périodique
avec dès demi-vies très variables,
et parmi eux, le fameux carbone 14.
Le carbone c'est le sixième élément
du tableau périodique
il possède donc 6 protons et suivant
le nombre de neutrons,
on a différents isotopes.
Vous en voyez ici une liste non exhaustive
avec les demi-vies associées,
le carbone 12 est stable
et c'est le plus courant
puisqu'il représente 99% du carbone
qu'on trouve sur terre,
le carbone 13 est stable également mais
c'est seulement 1% du total.
Quant au fameux carbone 14, eh bien
il n'est pas stable
mais sa demi-vie est vraiment longue:
5730 ans.
Ça veut dire quoi?
Imaginons que vous ayez un tas de carbone 14,
si vous attendez 5730 ans
il n'en, restera plus que la moitié, 50%.
Au bout de 11460 ans la moitié
de la moitié donc 25%
et à 17 190 ans seulement 12,5% etc.
La courbe complète est une exponentielle
décroissante
avec une demi-vie de 5730 ans,
et vous voyez peut-être,
qu'avec ce principe, il doit y avoir moyen
d'estimer l'âge de quelque chose
en regardant la quantité de carbone 14
qui lui reste,
plus il est vieux moins il doit en avoir.
Eh oui, sauf que pour ça il faudrait
connaître
la quantité qu'il en avait au départ
et en plus, 5730 ans, ça paraît long
mais, à l'échelle de l'univers,
c'est pas grand chose,
donc tout le carbone 14 de l'univers
devrait déjà s'être désintégré non?
Eh bien ce qui donne la réponse
à ces questions
c'est que du carbone 14 il en est produit
en permanence dans l'atmosphère,
cela provient du fait que les rayons
cosmiques viennent frapper
les molécules de l'air et transforme notamment
certains noyaux d'azote en carbone 14.
Ce carbone se retrouve ensuite rapidement
lié à de l'oxygène
et forme une molécule de co2
qui vient se mêler
aux autres molécules de co2
de l'atmosphère.
Donc d'un côté le carbone 14 se désintègre
naturellement,
de l'autre il est produit dans l'atmosphère
par les rayons cosmiques.
La conséquence de cela c'est que
le taux carbone 14
dans le co2 de l'atmosphère reste
à peu près constant,
c'est un taux très faible:
10 puissance moins 12,
ça veut dire que seulement
un atome de carbone
sur mille milliards est un atome
de carbone 14.
Alors maintenant, imaginez une plante
qui pousse tout le temps où elle est vivante,
elle fait de la photosynthèse donc elle
absorbe le co2 de l'atmosphère,
avec ça elle renouvelle en permanence
l'ensemble des molécules qui la composent
et son taux de carbone 14 reste donc constant,
égal au taux de l'atmosphère.
Mais le jour où cette plante meurt,
disons qu'elle est coupée
pour en faire quelque chose,
il n'y a plus de photosynthèse
ni de renouvellement du carbone
donc le taux de carbone 14 va commencer
à décroître
du fait de la désintégration radioactive,
et ce d'autant plus que le temps passe.
Évidemment, avec la chaîne alimentaire
ce raisonnement s'étend facilement
aux animaux,
le taux de carbone 14 dans un animal
qui se nourrit de végétaux
va être essentiellement constant,
et égal au taux de l'atmosphère,
et par extension, pareil pour
les carnivores.
Et notez que ça marche aussi
pour les espèces marines
puisque le co2 de l'atmosphère
se dissout dans l'océan,
on retrouve à peu près le même taux
chez les plantes et les animaux marins.
Au total on peut donc dire que, globalement
chez les êtres vivants,
le taux de carbone 14 est essentiellement
constant et connu,
tant qu'ils sont vivants,
et il ne se met à décroître
que quand ils meurent.
Donc ce que permet la datation au carbone 14
ce n'est pas tellement de connaître
l'âge d'un objet mais de savoir
depuis combien de temps la matière
qui le compose n'est plus vivante.
Donc ça marche quand il s'agit
de peaux animales,
de bois, de fibres textiles végétales,
éventuellement d'os ou de coquillages.
Donc quand on connaît le taux de carbone 14
d'un objet ancien par rapport
au taux de l'atmosphère en pourcentage
on prend la courbe de décroissance
et en reportant on peut, en quelque sorte
lire son âge.
Avec un taux égal à 80 %
du taux atmosphérique
l'objet date d'il y a environ 2000 ans,
si c'est 30% environ 10 000 ans,
10% pas loin de 20 000 ans etc.
Mais par contre attention,
vous ne pourrez pas
dater une épée en bronze au carbone 14,
ben oui il n'y a pas de carbone dedans,
Un diamant non plus d'ailleurs,
même si celui ci est effectivement
composé de carbone,
ça n'est pas du carbone d'origine
biologique,
donc il ne contient pas de carbone 14.
Ah oui, du coup le carbone 14 ça marche pas
non plus pour dater Michel Drucker
puisque, aux dernières nouvelles,
il est toujours vivant.
Je vous raconte tout ça en faisant
comme si c'était facile
de mesurer la quantité de carbone 14.
Mais en fait ça ne l'est pas du tout,
on l'a dit, le taux dans l'atmosphère
est super faible
c'est autour de 10 puissance moins 12,
un atome de carbone sur mille milliards,
donc si en plus une partie s'est désintégrée,
il faut être capable de mesurer ça
avec une précision très importante.
Une façon de compter la quantité
de carbone 14 dans un échantillon
c'est de mesurer son activité radioactive,
ben oui puisque le carbone 14 se désintègre,
plus on mesure de radioactivité
plus il y a de carbone 14.
Le problème c'est qu'il n'y en a déjà
pas beaucoup,
alors pour qu'une quantité significative
se désintègre
il faut effectuer la mesure sur
un échantillon assez gros,
au moins quelques dizaines de grammes
et pendant plusieurs jours.
L'autre façon de faire c'est ce qu'on appelle
la spectrométrie de masse,
on va compter les atomes de carbone
en les triant par masse
et oui car une des spécificités du carbone 14,
puisqu'il contient 8 neutrons au lieu de 6,
c'est justement d'être plus lourd
que le carbone 12.
Pour faire ça, on met pas les atomes
sur une balance,
mais on en fait un faisceau qu'on propulse
dans un champ magnétique pour le dévier.
Les noyaux les plus lourds ont plus d'inertie
ils seront donc moins déviés,
ce qui permet de séparer le faisceau
et de compter indépendamment
chaque isotope.
La spectrométrie de masse a l'avantage
de bien mieux compter les noyaux
de carbone 14
et donc permet d'utiliser des échantillons
d'une masse beaucoup plus faible,
souvent moins d'un gramme.
Bien, on a donc vu les grands principes
de la datation au carbone 14,
mais vous en voyez aussi les limites,
d'une part on ne peut pas
dater n'importe quoi et d'autre part
pour des objets trop vieux
eh bien ça ne marche pas.
Imaginons un objet ayant 50 000 ans,
sur la courbe on peut lire
que 99,9% de ses atomes de carbone 14
seront désintégrés
Sachant qu'au départ le carbone 14
ne représentait déjà
qu'un atome de carbone sur mille milliards,
ça fait qu'il en reste
un atome de carbone 14 pour un million
de milliards d'atomes.
Un million de milliards c'est en gros
le nombre de cheveux humains sur terre!
Donc c'est comme retrouver un cheveu
en particulier
sur l'ensemble des humains de la planète.
Bref, en gros au delà de 50 000 ans
les techniques de carbone 14
ne sont plus applicables.
Ça se voit d'ailleurs parce que si on prend
des hydrocarbures fossiles,
qui ont été des plantes mais il y a
bien longtemps,
eh bien il n'en contiennent plus du tout,
le taux de carbone 14 du pétrole
c'est zéro.
En plus des limitations qu'on vient de voir,
il faut savoir qu'il existe un certain nombre
de difficultés
qui rendent la technique plus
ou moins imprécises.
Un problème assez évident, c'est le risque
de contamination,
imaginons que vous vouliez dater
un petit morceau de textile retrouvé
dans un vieux tombeau,
si vous tripoter l'échantillon et que
vous laissez de la graisse de vos doigts,
vous allez apporter du carbone 14 récent,
ce qui va biaiser les mesures,
et plus l'échantillon est vieux,
plus une contamination risque
de fausser le résultat.
Une autre difficulté, c'est que contrairement
à ce que j'ai dit,
le taux de carbone 14 dans
les organismes vivants
n'est pas toujours exactement égal
à celui de l'atmosphère,
chimiquement un atome de carbone 14
c'est comme un atome de carbone 12,
il subit les mêmes réactions mais comme
il est un peu plus lourd,
certains processus peuvent se dérouler
à un rythme légèrement différent
ar rapport au carbone 12, par exemple
la photosynthèse sera plus fréquente
avec le carbone 12 mais au contraire
la dissolution dans les océans
sera plus facile avec le carbone 14,
il y a donc des petites corrections
à appliquer.
L'autre truc qui rend difficile
des estimations précises,
c'est que je vous ai dit que le taux
de carbone 14 dans l'atmosphère
était essentiellement constants
du fait de la production en continu
par les rayons cosmiques,
mais en fait on sait
que ce taux a très légèrement varié a
u cours des siècles
ce qui peut fausser les estimations.
Ce sont des choses qu'on a pu constater
et mesurer
grâce aux anneaux de certains arbres
très anciens
et qui ont ensuite permis de créer
des courbes de calibration.
Ce sont des courbes permettant de corriger
les estimations
pour tenir compte des très légères variations
du taux de carbone 14 au cours des siècles,
alors je parle de très légères variations
mais ça c'était avant,
en effet depuis quelques temps ce taux
a beaucoup varié
à cause de nous, les humains.
Premièrement on brûle des énergies fossiles
qui rejettent pas mal de co2
dans l'atmosphère et, on l'a dit,
il n'y a essentiellement
plus de carbone 14 dans les hydrocarbures
fossiles
donc ça fait baisser le taux de carbone 14
atmosphérique.
Mais bon, à l'inverse on a fait un autre
truc qui met bien le bazar
c'est de faire péter des bombes nucléaires
dans l'atmosphère,
à partir des années 1950 le taux
de carbone 14 dans l'atmosphère
est monté en flèche à cause de ça
et ça n'a commencé à décroître
qu'à partir de 1963 la date du traité
qui a banni les essais nucléaires en surface.
Autant dire que les archéologues
du cinquième millénaire
qui voudront faire de la datation
au carbone 14
sur notre civilisation, eh bien ils vont
s'amuser pour recalerles courbes.
Ah oui, la dernière difficulté,
quand le taux de carbone 14 varie
dans l'atmosphère ça ne se répercute pas
instantanément dans l'océan
surtout en profondeur, il peut y avoir
un décalage de plusieurs siècles,
ce qui complique encore les calibrations.
Mais bref, partons du principe
que les spécialistes de la datation
arrivent à corriger
au mieux tous ces effets perturbateurs
et voyons ce qu'on a pu faire avec.
[jingle]
La technique de datation au carbone 14
a été imaginée dans les années 1940
par le chimiste américain Willard Libby,
ça lui a valu d'ailleurs
le prix Nobel en 1960.
Au départ on n'avait pas de certitudes
quant à la capacité de cette technique
à faire des datations précises,
Libby a donc commencé
par prendre des vestiges archéologiques
dont on connaissait assez bien la date,
et a montré que la datation au carbone 14
conduisait à des résultats
similaires à ceux qu'on avait déjà.
Les datations archéologiques ont permis
de valider la technique du carbone 14
et on verra que maintenant ça se passe
plutôt dans l'autre sens.
Une des utilisations les plus fameuses
du carbone 14
ça a été la datation des manuscrits
de la Mer Morte
il s'agit d'un grand ensemble de parchemin
et de papyrus
qui ont été retrouvés dans des grottes
en Palestine entre les années 1946 et 1956,
sur ces parchemins on a trouvé notamment
de nombreux textes de la Bible hébraïque,
que les religions chrétiennes appellent
l'Ancien Testament.
Jusqu'ici le plus ancien manuscrit connu
de ces textes c'était le codex d'Alep,
dont on estime qu'il a été écrit entre
l'an 910 et 93o de notre ère évidemment.
À la découverte des manuscrits la Mer Morte,
on a voulu connaître leur âge
pour savoir où il se situaient
par rapport à ça.
Eh bien le carbone 14 a permis de les dater,
les plus vieux aurait été écrits
en moins 250,
c'est-à-dire plus de mille ans
avant le codex d'Alep,
un bond dans le passé incroyable,
d'une importance capitale,
pour ceux qui étudient la façon dont
ces textes religieux ont évolué
au cours des siècles.
Alors un point toutefois
dans cette histoire,
la réponse n'est pas venue seulement
du carbone 14
mais également de ce qu'on appelle
la paléographie
c'est-à-dire l'étude des écritures
manuscrites anciennes,
et cette méthode a donné des résultats
similaires au carbone 14
pour estimer l'âge des parchemins.
C'est important car souvent
sur des questions compliquées
comme les datations archéologiques,
il faut utiliser une combinaison
de techniques
pour affiner les estimations,
le carbone 14 n'a pas toujours
seul réponse à tout .
Un autre exemple célèbre de datation,
c'est celui de ce qu'on appelle
la carte du Vinland.
Il s'agit d'une drôle de mappemonde
dessinée sur un parchemin
qui a fait surface à la fin des années 50
et représente supposément le monde connu
aux environs du 13ème siècle.
Le truc bizarre il est là regardez,
on voit le Groenland bon, OK,
mais plus à l'ouest ce qui est représenté
comme une sorte d'île avec deux larges
embouchures de fleuves.
Ça évoque quand même furieusement la côte
est de l'Amérique du Nord,
au 13ème siècle!
L'endroit est noté comme étant le "Vinland"
et c'est le nom qu'aurait donné le Viking
Leif Erikson
à un territoire qu'il a exploré autour
de l'an mil
et dont on pense qu'il s'agit justement
du Nord de l'Amérique.
On a d'ailleurs retrouvé depuis
des vestiges vikings
sur les côtes de Terre-neuve au Canada.
Si on croit à l'authenticité de ce document
ce serait donc une trace de la cartographie
des côtes de l'Amérique du Nord
par les vikings, et ce bien
avant Christophe Colomb
alors qu'en dit le carbone 14?
Eh bien, des analyses menées sur
le parchemin ont permis
de le dater d'une façon assez précise
entre 1423 et 1445
donc clairement avant Christophe Colomb,
sauf que!
Sauf que cette datation ne concerne
que le parchemin, le support de la carte,
imaginez que le parchemin soit
effectivement ancien
mais que le tracé soit un faux réalisé
au 20ème siècle.
Pour savoir ça il faudrait analyser l'encre,
mais c'est pas possible de faire une datation
au carbone 14 qui porte juste sur l'encre.
Alors depuis des analyses chimiques ont
quand même révélé que cette encre
contiendrait d'ailleurs du dioxyde
de titane,
un composé qu'on ne sait fabriquer
que depuis 1920,
ce qui jette un sérieux doute sur
l'authenticité de la carte.
Mais bon aujourd'hui le débat n'est
pas encore complètement tranché.
Dans la même veine le carbone 14
a aussi permis de dater
le fameux manuscrit Voynich,
un livre écrit dans un code que personne
n'a encore réussi à déchiffrer
et qui aurait donc été écrit
entre 1404 et 1438.
Parmi les autres datation fameuse
il y a aussi
ce qu'on appelle l'évangile de Judas,
il s'agit d'un manuscrit en papyrus
présentant
un évangile attribué à Judas Iscariote,
l'apôtre qui a trahi Jésus.
C'est ce qu'on appelle un évangile apocryphe
c'est-à-dire qu'il n'est pas reconnu
par l'église catholique,
et pour cause il présente l'histoire
sous un jour assez différent
puisque, dans cet évangile, Judas aurait
trahi sur ordre de Jésus.
Toujours est il qu'on a pu analyser
ce manuscrit au carbone 14
et il date du 3ème siècle, 3ème siècle
après Jésus-Christ évidemment!
Dans les usages plus académique
du carbone 14
on peut mentionner cette récente étude
d'envergure
qui en 2010 a permis de réviser et d'ajuster
toute la chronologie de l'Égypte ancienne.
Je vous l'ai dit initialement il a fallu
valider la technique du carbone 14
à partir d'objets dont on connaissait
approximativement la date,
eh bien maintenant, la méthode est
si efficace
qu'elle permet de venir compléter
voire réviser certaines estimations
archéologiques.
Il faut dire qu'en ce qui concerne l'Égypte
ancienne c'est assez compliqué.
Quand on doit faire des datations
et notamment
établir une chronologie des pharaons,
on se base en général sur
des textes écrits.
Sauf qu'on en a déjà pas forcément
à la pelle et en plus
à l'époque, les scribes avaient
une fâcheuse tendance
à rebooter les dates chaque fois
qu'il y avait un nouveau pharaon,
on comptait les années à partir du début
du règne du souverain.
Grâce à ça on a parfois des bonnes
estimations relatives
entre les événements mais ça n'est pas
du tout évident
de positionner le tout sur
un calendrier absolu,
d'attribuer des années précises
aux différents règnes.
Prenons un exemple: le célèbre
pharaon Khéops,
celui qui a construit la grande pyramide
de Gizeh,
on pense que son règne a duré
entre 25 et 45 ans
et que c'était quelque part au 26ème siècle
avant notre ère
donc entre moins 2600 et moins 2500.
Mais il y a un débat autour
de la date précise,
d'après la chronologie établie par
l'égyptologue Ian Shaw
son règne aurait commencé en moins 2589.
Mais d'après la chronologie d'Erik Hornung,
un autre égyptologue
ce serait plutôt moins 2509, ça fait 80 ans
de différence quand même.
Et récemment une nouvelle théorie
a été proposée
en se basant sur l'orientation
de la pyramide de Khéops
par rapport aux points cardinaux
et a avancé une estimation encore
plus récente - 2480.
Bon, donc en gros on a cent ans
d'incertitudes
sur le début du règne de Khéops,
et pour tous les pharaons on a
ce genre de problèmes,
surtout pour les plus anciennes dynasties,
on a du mal à mettre des dates absolues
Mais donc, en 2010 une grande étude
a essayé de mettre tout le monde d'accord.
L'idée était d'utiliser une méthode
prenant en compte à la fois
les données archéologiques et de nouvelles
mesures au carbone 14
qui se voulaient le plus précises possible.
Pour ça les auteurs ont notamment choisi
d'utiliser préférentiellement
des graines et des textiles
car ils permettent d'avoir des estimations
plus précises
que des objets par exemple en bois.
Ben oui, prenez un vieil arbre,
même s'il est toujours vivant
seule l'écorce et les feuilles
vont se renouveler
mais ça n'est pas le cas pour
le cœur du tronc,
qui est en quelque sorte déjà mort,
bah oui hein,
pensez-y un arbre vivant en fait,
à l'intérieur, il est déjà mort…
un peu comme Michel Drucker!
Et donc si un pharaon s'est taillé
un sceptre en bois
dans le cœur d'un vieil arbre
et s'est fait enterrer avec
eh bien l'âge de l'arbre peut fausser
beaucoup la datation.
D'où l'idée de n'utiliser que des choses
qui laissent moins d'ambiguïté
comme des graines, grâce à 200 datations
de ce genre,
l'étude a fournit une estimation de la date
de début de règne
d'une quarantaine de pharaons couvrant
une période
allant de moins 2600 à moins 1100,
c'est-à-dire du début de l'ancien empire
à la fin du nouvel empire.
Voici une représentation graphique
des résultats,
en abscisse vous avez les dates et on voit
les trois périodes correspondantes,
Ancien Empire, Moyen Empire, et Nouvel Empire
et dans chacune de ces périodes vous avez
une liste des principaux souverains,
la position verticale c'est juste
l'ordre chronologique.
Pour chaque souverain on voit
une petite barre rouge
qui indique l'estimation de début de règne
d'après l'égyptologue Ian Shaw,
en bleu d'après Erik Hornung
et en vert d'après la théorie
sur l'orientation des pyramides.
Et par dessus tout ça la courbe grisée
représente
la distribution de probabilité
du début de règne calculée par l'étude.
La date la plus probable est
au pic de la courbe
et la largeur de la courbe mesure
en gros l'incertitude.
Prenons l'exemple de Khéops dont
le nom égyptien est Khufu,
on voit que l'estimation de l'étude
colle très bien
avec la chronologie rouge
celle de Ian Shaw
et semble en désaccord net avec
les deux autres estimations.
On retrouve à peu près le même phénomène
sur tous les souverains de l'Ancien Empire
et sur les derniers l'estimation est même
encore plus antérieure à la chronologie de Shaw.
Pour les souverains du Moyen Empire,
c'est pareil en moins prononcé
et pour le Nouvel Empire ben on voit
que les courbes sont plus resserrées,
on a moins d'incertitudes
car la période est plus récente.
Évidemment il se pourrait que les choses
bougent encore un peu
avec de nouvelles mesures où
de nouvelles découvertes,
mais avoir une chronologie absolue
plus fiable à de nombreux avantages.
Ça permet par exemple de mieux comparer
l'histoire de l'Égypte ancienne
avec celle des civilisations voisines
comme la Mésopotamie
et donc, en quelque sorte de pouvoir recoller
les deux chronologies de façon absolue.
Cependant comme on l'a dit, le carbone 14
a ses limites et il ne permet pas,
par exemple, de dater des vestiges datant
de plus de 50 mille ans.
En histoire ça va, mais pour les fossiles
des paléoanthropologues
ça devient compliqué.
Heureusement il existe d'autres méthodes,
par exemple celle du béryllium 10
il s'agit d'un isotope dont la demi-vie
est de 1,4 million d'années
il est lui aussi produit dans l'atmosphère
mais se retrouve sur les sols
du fait des précipitations ce qui permet
de dater des sédiments.
C'est notamment grâce à cette technique
qu'il a été possible
de dater le squelette de Toumaï,
le plus ancien fossile connu
de la lignée humaine, dont l'âge est ainsi
estimé à sept millions d'années,
soit plus du double de l'âge
de la célèbre Lucy
Et sinon je pourrais aussi vous parler
de la datation à l'uranium/plomb
qui a permis d'estimer l'âge du plus vieil
objet terrestre connu,
une roche de zircon, vieille
de 4,4 milliards d'années.
Mais bon, on va quand même pas commencer à
parler cailloux sur cette chaîne!
Voilà, c'est tout pour aujourd'hui.
Vous trouverez comme toujours des compléments
et précisions
dans le billet de blog qui accompagne la vidéo.
Abonnez vous, mettez la cloche tout ça,
et je vous dis à très vite pour
des nouvelles vidéos.
À bientôt.
[Musique]
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -